[Music]  right before Christmas a good guy in red  is coming to theaters with his new  sidekick  Fred why am I here you're in a pg-13  version of Deadpool filtered through the  prison of childlike innocence and no man  has childlike innocence like you've had  nobody I need you almost as much as you  need me I don't need you at all me to  untie you once we're done  I'm left you're working up I'm sorry  don't get to a test once upon a Deadpool  character for Marvel movies we are  marvel  yeah but you're you know Marvel license  by Fox it's like if the Beatles were  produced by Nickelback it's music but it  sucks you were nicer as a kid rated  pg-13 limited engagement in theaters  December 12th  [Music]